there's no formula for it and I think
like I what became a surprise hit for me
is I do threads where I say how
fictional characters voted in the EU
referendum and I just was just before I
got on a train
I said how all the characters in Thomas
the Tank Engine definitely you
referendum I got on the train and I open
my laptop like 20 minutes later and I'm
like it's got like a thousand likes how
is this happening this is the most
stupid
there is no masking is that yeah I mean
these seem like sort of in a way silly
questions
- I don't mean to to denigrate what you
don't mean they're a bit but they but
obviously but inside you know for
example a brush queueing conservative HQ
there are people and and Lib Dem HQ
there are people trying to crack the
formula what does well on social media
how do you do it
I've people people have asked me they
said oh my can you come up with some
viral content no I can't no no no no no
no it's dense yeah live games the just
agencies agents yeah it's desperate for
viral content and you just can't say
well this will and that won't you know
and you know the the way the the tourism
neighbor have have tried to create me me
things during the selection has been I'd
say for the most part pretty cringe
inducing I think I just don't think the
things that they've tried worked because
they're trying to there's nothing worse
than a politician trying to be funny